[Music]
a cold land of cold machines
we psychins
are always chasing the next big thing
dr bergstrom
i am nothing like him
i'm better than him
beyond him
to be second is to evolve after all
i'll make you regret choosing stern over
me gunslinger
[Music]
but you were in
the laboratory
can't you see
you're in the way
of progress
no matter time to shed this useless body
the gods cursed me with
behold true evolution
gun of yours doesn't have enough bullets
for all of us specialists
no one
can stop
kaiser in
you think you have some
great
destiny
well i'll be watching
greetings
destiny has led you here
[Music]
welcome to the edge of the world
trixian
now follow
the path of the light
[Music]
[Music]
the forces of chaos
are on the move again
the arks once saved the world from the
demons
we need them again
try opening the tome of prophecy
it will show you the path
of your destiny
hmm
oh
[Music]
[Music]
may regulus bless the path you've chosen
[Music]